Film Courage: What was your first job in film and
television when you arrived in Los Angeles?
Brad Sykes, Filmmaker: The first movie job I ever had was on
movie called KISS THE GIRLS which was
this Paramount Pictures movie I worked on in 96
summer of 96 was between my third and
fourth year film school and the director
that movies Gareth leader who's from my
hometown and I knew him and he also went
to Boston University where I went to
film school so we had those two things
in common and I get an I had gotten in
touch with Gary a little bit before that
just wrote him a letter saying I'm you
know this young a film student the young
filmmaker from Virginia Beach now isn't
he actually gotten back to me and and
and been very encouraging and he
actually told me I'm gonna be making
this movie you know this little movie
with Morgan Freeman and would you like
to work on that so it was perfect timing
because it was you know the summer and I
was able to work on that was essentially
an internship for school but it was like
a real working internship because I got
to see four I worked on it for about two
months two and a half months and just
see the whole inner workings of a movie
in a big movie to you know a thirty-five
million dollar movie and it was just it
was just a very cool experience and Gary
was great to give me that opportunity
and I learned I learned a lot about I
would say things that I think are good
and also bad in terms of the
wastefulness sometimes the big studios
and you know the sort of the standing
around and not not much going on but it
was just such an invaluable experience
just to see like you know how the how
movies are made the Paramount a lot all
of that so it was just a really cool and
I loved being on set that was something
I learned I had made shorts and even
features with my friends on video up to
that point but it was the first time
we've been on a professional movie set
and I just loved the atmosphere the set
with the bustling crew and all the
things that go on you know I enjoyed it
a lot
I think I rented that movie a
blockbuster that was a hit movie
yes we're Morgan Freeman and Ashley Judd
see them on the side yeah exactly I mean
they were they were both really cool I'm
Brad to buy a birthday present for
Morgan Freeman at one point they said go
go go birthday present for Morgan
Freeman I said well what does he like he
likes boats big on boating so I bought
him a book about boats and the other
thing I remembered about Ashley Judd and
she was pretty new back then it was one
of her maybe her first big movie is she
baked brownies for the PAS
she was super nice she brought it had
somebody bring ice cream down one tell
like a cart like a haagen-dazs cart like
just ice cream for everyone on the crew
I mean she was really cool and I mean in
Frank it was a lot of cool people you
know it was a lot of cool people in the
film and it was a great introduction to
LA for me because I had never even I
mean I think I'd been out here once
prior to that just visiting a friend for
like a week and every day you're going
to a different location and it was kind
of funny because my dad came out here
with me at first you know to help me
move into this apartment I was like
renting a room in this apartment in the
valley and he's like I'm gonna we'll go
we'll go the location like you know
because we got the call sheet you know
he's like we'll go through the location
the day before so you know where to go
and how to get there he was just trying
to help you know and we did go to the
location which was a hospital and an
abandoned Hospital in downtown or
something well that was great for the
first day or the second day but then we
had a company move and then we did
another company so basically I was you
know I had a crash course in LA freeways
and directions and music oh this is in
96 so you know no GPS you know using the
Thomas guide and the call sheets and the
directions they would give you those
little maps and sometimes I went you
know I messed up but I always made it to
set every day on time group relatively
on time so because they couldn't have
started without me you know but it was
it was a real learning experience yeah
how soon after that did you make a full
move or that room in that apartment was
your full month that was no I was just
there for the summer in fact I should
probably mention the other flip side of
that the other experience I had was I
worked at scott-free productions Ridley
Scott's company after kiss the girls
that same summer I interned over there
as a script reader for about a month
month and a half and that was
interesting it was like
going from the state you know the set
work every day or a new location you're
in the woods you're in wherever the
beach and then to being an office in
Beverly Hills every day air-conditioned
with you know Kern's nectars up there
for everybody to take and you know I
have to say nice people really nice
people I've learned a lot but I was so
much more fan of being on set
that was something I discovered about
myself that summer for sure in terms of
what direction I wanted to go in the
movie business I didn't move out here
until the following summer 97 and that
was right after graduation and I had a
job lined up literally once again got a
call from another director to work on a
movie which I was fortunate to to be
able to do so quickly you know so then
once I moved out here in the summer of
97 I stayed and that's been here ever
since I think it's such a valuable thing
for people at a young age to know either
they're not the office guy or they're
not the I'm gonna be out there yeah
seat of my pants trying to figure stuff
out yeah it was I mean it was just I'm
because I my favorite part of filmmaking
is the shoot that's never changed
whether I was a teenager work now and
being in an office it was interesting to
read scripts and I'm reading a lot of
scripts while I was there I read you
know first time ever read a Tarantino
script on the on the page first I read a
Kevin Williamson script first time I
read I don't know they had a bunch of
interesting things over there you know
and things they were not necessarily the
things they were making because they
weren't making as much stuff as they do
now they're making like a movie a year
back then now they're like huge you know
they've got TV shows and movies running
all the time but it was it was just yeah
development was not really my thing not
because I I love reading and I love
writing and I came into this into film
as a writer you know more than the
director initially but I just enjoy the
set experience this sort of you know
adventure of being unset more did you
have a car when you first came to LA I
did yeah you had a car my dad and I
drove cross-country from Virginia oh
that's some
we drove what was it that was an
adventure - you know we drove
cross-country kind of followed almost
like the old route 66 at least for part
of it and it took about a week I think
for us to drive at or maybe less than a
week I was like four days but anyway we
we drove out here and I had a yeah I had
a car got out of a car you know
especially on that on kiss the girls I
mean your you know driving - one day
you're driving the El Segundo and there
you're driving to the Malibu one day
you're driving to you know Santa Clarita
right did it almost spoil things for you
cuz you know how when you have a really
great first experience with something
then you think everything else that's
gonna be like that and in some sets are
amazing and everybody gets along and
it's like a very special experience yeah
and then others it's actually not that
way well I have to tell you the two
movies I worked on after that were much
more special experiences for me
and they were lower budget movies they
were more like in the million dollar
range per movie because the first two
films I worked on out here was a movie
called spoiler was a sci-fi action movie
and then the next movie was actually
filmed in Romania and that was a kids
movie kind of kids horror movie and
these were you know low-budget films
direct-to-video movies made you know
mostly under one roof like I remember
the spoiler was filmed entirely in
Burbank under in this stage used to be
an old warehouse or something and they
shot three movies there in a row they
just switched out the walls repainted
certain parts of it they shot three
movies in a row and our movie was the
third movie and I'm ever when they had a
rap party they had a wrap party for all
three producers the producers didn't
feel like springing for three wrap
parties so we just had one it was a big
wrap party there I met a lot of people
with that wrap party and then the one in
Romania was even lower budget and it was
like the most fun thing I'd ever most
fun I've ever had in my life you know so
the big budget thing you know the
paramount thing was a great learning
experience but it was and I didn't have
that sense of fun and sense of
creativity and I should also bring up
very importantly that on spoiler I was
able to direct second unit as a you know
22 year old recent Film School grad I
had it was given a designated DP AC and
35-millimeter Panavision camera and I
was allowed to direct second unit on
this movie so you know that's something
that was that surely wouldn't have
happened on kiss the girls and that was
because of the director I was working
with and he was just a super nice guy
Jeff Burr who took me under his wing and
you know brought me onto these films so
I guess the lesson from that might be
that you know the lower budget movies
you learn more you get to do more you
get to have more creative input
sometimes into things and you get to
know everybody a bit more too because
there's not as many people working you
know there aren't like maybe there's 50
people working versus a hundred or 200
or something like that you know
so all great experiences though you know
at what point did you say you were not
done working on sets for other people
but you wanted to be driving your own
film your own content you know I never
had a specific point where I stopped in
fact the first directing writing
directing job I got was so low paid that
I didn't stop doing those those set jobs
it was a movie called scream queen and
and I was thrilled to get the
opportunity to write and direct but you
know almost immediately after that I
went back to doing I was doing special
effects assistant work and production
assistant work and stuff like that so I
kept doing that but and that kind of
went on a little bit like that for a
year or two but you know what's
interesting about that is on those
bigger films that I was piaying on or
doing special effects I met a lot of
people I met a lot of professional good
people effects artists and you know
camera people and all this kind of thing
so that my movies when I start to get to
direct more and more I was able to bring
them onto those stems or at least
consult with them and they would like
say recommend an intern who was really
good or something like that so I think
that was a really good thing and it's
something that I always I still believe
it now that peep
should who want to get in the business
and you know everybody wants to direct
and everybody can't wait to direct but
it's really really good to work on other
positions you know in other departments
and learn from those departments and
learn from that experience and see how
sets are run and see what works and what
doesn't work which you like and don't
like and also you will meet people and
and those people will be the people you
work with or you call favors from when
you do direct a short or a feature so
that's that's kind of how it happened
for me now scream queens that's I
remember Rhonda Shear used to do the
USAF all night and show like movies like
yeah it was some really just fascinating
I know a lot of people who made those
movies I'm that's that's no I used to
watch that show too it was okay well the
scream queen had this actress named
Linea Quigley who's okay so you know she
is well she was the star of our movie
and once again I our movie wasn't really
it was a very modest film but because I
had worked on other stuff and I knew
other you know new people I was able to
call in a favor at least my friend and
say hey would you you I know you know
Linnea would you be willing to tell
Annie about this movie we're trying to
make and would she be willing to read
the script and that's how we got the
script to her and I met with her had a
great sit-down meeting with her and you
know and she was she was in it was not a
huge time commitment for her and we also
sort of repaid the favor by shooting a
music video for a song that she had done
at the time she had a song called this
chainsaw is made for cuttin it was sort
of the Nancy Sinatra like that so we did
the you know so she acted in her movie
for a couple of days we did a music
video for her and you know we had fun
doing it and of course for me it was
really cool to work with her but yes she
was in a lot of those type of films she
is a scream queen she's a major scream
queen and that's why she was in the
movie in the first place was it was sort
of a self-referencing kind of a
Hollywood on Hollywood movie you know
that was that was the idea with that one
so we were really it was really cool to
have her in the film was a good start
for for me
you